like just about everything else in the
world sports is being consumed by woke
ideology athletes protest the anthem
ESPN preaches social justice biological
males annihilate records in girls sports
barstool sports meanwhile is just a
sports site with a sense of humor that's
the most offensive part to many they are
funny and for that they come under
constant attack most recently an NBC
News piece fault the website for being
recording now a bastion of traditional
masculinity Dave Portnoy founder
barstool sports he joins us tonight so
Dave NBC has gone after you for being
masculine we out responds well not only
masculine for like in sports they have a
problem with sports literally like
direct quote there's so many so many
head scratchers in this article I don't
even know where to start but that's some
of them they say we're overwhelmingly
conservative not really true we're eight
we're eight political I've told you that
but it literally says they are a passion
of conservative ideology because they
watch sports guess what we like sports
we're not apologizing for it guess what
women like sports - it's almost like say
making the NFL like well if the NFL must
be conservative because guys like
football it makes no sense none no it
doesn't it doesn't and by the way I've
said this before I would be shocked if
you know there are a lot of
right-wingers on your staff you're just
doing what you've always done but all of
a sudden the moment has changed so much
they're calling you political so the
piece contains this is my favorite part
it contains a quote from the following
Lisa Nakamura who's described as a
professor at Ann Arbor quote who studies
the intersection of digital media race
gender and sexuality and you know my
school that's my school that hurts I'm a
Michigan guy we're going downhill every
week we get killed by Wisconsin we're
getting embarrassed by this lady
it's disgusting it is actually there's
one of the more serious like threats you
look at some of these articles they're
all professors and all these schools
it's like what are you teaching these
kids and by the way Tucker we reach out
to these people hey do you have any
interests in defending anything you say
none of them goes they don't call us
they don't talk to us
they just make up stuff
they're cowards they won't come on the
show either so did have you ever had
anybody respond and say yeah I'd like to
defend the proposition that it's wrong
for a sports site to cover sports they
just ignore you know they say no and how
are you gonna defend it a lot of this
article says we're going back in time
like as the me2 movement and women are
getting more power in different places
we're rejecting that notion
it's our CEO is a female by the way
which in its own right is insulting to
have to bring it up she's a CEO because
she's brilliant I didn't hire her
because she's female she's awesome and
the results speak for themselves
but what are you gonna do in our CMOS a
female our CFO is a female you look
around like what are you talking about
you're just making stuff up that's why
they don't answer it NBC hey I've
offered to go on that show you know what
they do they cancel because they know
they have no answers listen everyone's
like you only go on Fox you only do
Tucker Tucker the only one who lets us
speak I'll speak to anybody anytime
anyplace but if they're afraid to have
these questions as what am I supposed to
do you let us get our story out I worked
there for four years at NBC and so I
know how many pigs work there for real
but I wonder given their deep commitment
to feminism like what percentage of the
profits from the Olympics do you think
they're giving to women's organizations
oh I don't know the years of that I know
this I know they killed a Harvey
Weinstein's story I know they've had
their own hey look in the mirror just
look in the mirror NBC and I'm not
either way I'll gladly go on your show
you know you don't have when I present
you with facts you're gonna turtle
you're gonna roll over they just make
stuff up and then if you can't dispute
it you won't debate it what are you
supposed to do and by the way they may
have actually if they think it's a
problem to watch sports that means
you're conservative guess what
conservatives have the presidency for
the rest of time because people like
sports so Andy lack and Noah Oppenheim
over at NBC is you just point out kill
the Harvey Weinstein story and now
accuse you of sexism I wonder when
either one of those ever do an interview
with you you think do you think anybody
again the facts are so heavily weighted
on our side it makes no you read that
our
there were sentences in that article I
read them a hundred times I think I'm a
fairly smart person I still didn't know
what they were driving at like the Dean
of communication school at Penn State
you know if you listen to what she said
I would never let my kid in her class
what world is she insane sports centric
going back in time in his insanity and
again I am happy to debate it I will go
to your class Marie Hardin I will let
you have the moderator I'll let you put
your people and I'll put you in a mental
pretzel because you have no facts don't
send your kids to college that really is
the lesson I don't want to send my forth
I mean that completely they're great to
see you tonight
god bless you thank you